hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my arrow finale video just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
they've already said a few things about
season five and I'll talk about what's
going on with all the other shows at the
end of this - isn't it funnier when you
think about how arrow is typically
thought of is the darker show the flash
is typically a lighter show but the
arrow finale is way more hopeful than
the flash finale but all I feel like
arrows headed in a good direction but
I'll like explain if you want to do some
homework for arrow season five watch the
wire from HBO seasons four and five
there's a storyline in that where
Littlefinger from Game of Thrones
becomes the mayor like he campaigns for
then becomes the mayor there's a lot of
drama surrounding that arrow has
inspired a lot by the wire in addition
to Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy and we'll talk a little bit
about that too but the overarching
message of the episode is that a hero is
always going to have darkness in him but
being a hero means not succumbing to
that darkness they're just learning to
live with it which is a very broad based
metaphor and there were a couple points
during the season where I felt like they
got really ham-fisted with the way they
talked about that so I'll explain as we
go along so top five WTF in Easter eggs
and I'll explain the Oliver Queen Maher
storyline from the comics at number five
WTF damian darhk-- versus Felicity's
mother forced choking he stops an arrow
midair you can tell even though they've
reduced arrows budget to supernatural
levels like supernatural is a good
example of a TV show with an incredibly
low budget usually as TV shows get on in
seasons they reduce their budget so
that's why you don't see as many special
effects on arrows you do on a show like
the flash but the way they filmed it the
things that we're going on were really
cool I don't want to blow up the world
because my mother is in it number four
Baron Rider takes down the plane midair
darth vader style this is actually very
similar to a panel in a Star Wars comic
book where Vader crushes a plane midair
there is always going to be so much Star
Wars just peppered all over DC comic
books TV shows any sci-fi in general
number three was the way they treated
characters die so in the flashbacks
Oliver ends up killing Taiana in present
day Lyla totally gives Diggle a pass for
killing Andi and Felicity talks her old
boyfriend into committing suicide
effectively don't you remember how we
talked about saving the world the more
important parts of this I think are the
Diggle in the flashback Oliver storyline
Prez
de Diggle is effectively going through
the same arc that flashback Oliver is
flashback Oliver hasn't got to the point
where he's realized that sometimes
heroes don't have a choice you have to
kill someone Diggle and present-day
hasn't come to that conclusion yet
number two team arrow goes at separate
ways the title of the episode was schism
they teased that for a long time so I
feel like this wasn't a big surprise
even Stephen Amell when people asked him
to tease season five he said where'd
everybody go
so it was like okay team arrow very
clearly going to go their separate ways
for a little while before they come back
together but even though they're
standing there in the air okay that's
empty it's still been trashed they
haven't cleaned it up yet Felicity's
still there Oliver's looking at the
costume so that's just a way to tell you
that he's not going to stop being the
green arrow they're not going to stop
being team arrow it's just that a lot of
the team is in Netflix and chill mode
they're putting their sweats on and
they'll be back after they finished
marathon and Game of Thrones number one
of course is mayor Oliver Queen Oliver
taking the oath of office then telling
him that it's only temporary you're
going to have to go through this again
in August which if you guys are charting
this arrow moves in real time so October
is the beginning of the season so we'll
probably see some sort of campaign at
the beginning of the season with the new
villain coming and that'll probably be
the arc that introduces him Stephen
Amell said that they weren't directly
teasing the season 5 villain but some
clues as to how he would appear and what
that would be like and they also said
that he would not be a metahuman he
wouldn't have superpowers which is why I
think Oliver is going to be battling the
villain as mayor Oliver Queen and the
green arrow like a lot of arrow season 4
was spent at dark that's also kind of a
metaphor for the darkness damian darhk--
but arrow season 5 seems like it's going
to be a little more balanced so we'll
see a lot more daytime scenes like we
did in season 1 we'll see a lot more
Oliver Queen being mayor trying to deal
with that and for those of you that are
asking about crossover with the flash
and flash point all the stuff that
happened with the flash finale just
careful for spoilers from that episode
if you haven't seen the flash finale yet
because of the way modern television
works and it's written there will be
crossover there will be ripples felt
from what Barry did the way he changed
the past but it's not going to be on the
level of comic book flashpoint so during
Comic Book flashpoint the entire DC
Universe is changed the Justice League
goes to war with each other it's not
going to be like that on air
Erol will still have its own plot line
but I think the negative consequences of
Berry's actions will mostly affect him
in the relationships of the characters
on the flash TV show but they will have
to address it on the other TV shows
because it seems like Barry will not be
the flash when season 3 picks up because
in the original timeline of the flash he
still became the flash but when the
reverse flash came back the first time
he sped that up he's like I need you to
become the flash a little bit faster
than before so that all played out over
season one of the flash but now Barry
has kind of reset that so he'll still
become the flash but it depends on what
point he goes back in the future if he
goes back to the exact moment he left he
will not be the flash all the
relationships will have been changed so
I know it sounds a little complicated
but it'll be vastly simpler than it
sounds when we actually end up seeing it
and there will still be a four-way
crossover so at some point Barry's gonna
get his powers back and we'll see our
big Justice Society team-up but let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite thing about the arrow finale I
feel like we were all expecting Oliver
to come there so I'm really happy that
they're pushing into that comic book
story but I think one of my complaints
against arrow season 4 in general is
just that it seems like they were kind
of all over the place they they were
wildly inconsistent with episodes and a
lot of that I think has to do with all
the work that they had to do launching
legends of tomorrow because Marc
Guggenheim is the arrow showrunner he's
like the comic book guy in the room he
writes good episodes but it seems like
he spent most of this year helping
legends of tomorrow writing scripts for
that show so that means that he had to
take a bunch of time away from arrow so
what happens when you lose like the most
important person on your staff
it just becomes a bit of a problem when
people were asking Stephen Amell about
big crossovers next year he said that
he's really excited they do not have to
launch a new show so just the way he was
talking about it made it sound like he
was a little upset with the way arrow
was treated this season from a
production standpoint so just to explain
mayor Oliver Queen from the comic books
so Oliver became mayor of Star City in
the wake of what happened during
Infinite Crisis there was this big idea
that ran across all DC's titles called
one year later checking in with everyone
1 year after Infinite Crisis the green
arrow storyline was called crawling
through the wreckage as in literally
crawling through the wreckage of Star
City so that's kind of what's happening
on arrow
three disasters as mister terrific's
edit I like that joke after living
through three disasters in the city we
were ready to bail till the green arrow
gave us hope that's kind of what
happened in the comics so Oliver becomes
mayor and tries to rebuild the city the
funny thing is is you know the
rebuilding the city during that story in
the comics but the people that blew the
city you this will sound familiar the
people who physically blew the city up
were Merlyn in dr. lights so we all know
Merlyn did that in season one so arrow
has mixed and matched a lot of big story
points in the comics the undertaking was
effectively what happened before one
year later so you can see how arrow has
kind of split up the mayor Oliver Queen
one year later story line with the
undertaking in season one it's kind of
stretched that across arrow seasons one
two now Deathstroke was a big part of
that arc but they've already done him on
the television show Constantine Drakken
would be an awesome person but they
didn't during season one he was a really
minor villain it was Lana like Komodo
Komodo is a really big character in the
comics but the TV show turned him into a
smaller villain
Richard dragon would be my Big Pig for a
huge comic book character that feels
really big that they haven't done on the
show yet so let me know in the comments
who do you think the big bad for season
5 is going to be he can't have powers
and it's probably going to be someone we
haven't seen in the arrowverse yet but
the only other things that I'd know that
the probably follow up on during season
5 are that new black Canary technically
she's not the Black Canary so we'll just
call her Evelyn Crawford for now she's a
different comic book character but this
season they made it seem like she was
going to be the new version of the
canary I don't think they want to
trample on laurels memory right away so
she's not going to be a series regular
next year but we'll probably see her and
maybe like a mini arc otherwise I feel
like we all expect them to go to Russia
with the flashbacks next year remains to
be seen what they'll do with the
flashbacks after season 5 because they'd
only plotted out five seasons worth of
flashbacks but I think Stephen Amell
said they have some ideas about what to
do after that because he's under
contract through seven seasons but that
doesn't guarantee the arrow will go
seven seasons I am expecting seven
seasons but a lot can happen between now
and then so believe it when we see it
but if I hadn't said it before mr.
terrific has been upped to series
regular for season five so he'll be in
most of the episodes and I should say he
saved the finale for me they were
so broad and on the nose with that hope
and darkness theme but mr. terrific
speech completely tied it all together
and made it work before Oliver gave his
speech so high fives the mr. terrific
for saving the episode but what's going
to happen next is I'm working on a
preacher video I have my flash season
three predictions so those videos will
post tomorrow be sure to subscribe to
get them there is a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my flash finale video and you can
click here to learn all about DC rebirth
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight